we have a voicemail number, at least for now,
unless the audience says they want to change,
that number is two one nine two David p here
is an idea from a conservative who says the
entire premise of the show is wrong.
The entire focus of my political philosophy
is wrong and this should basically just become
a right wing show.
Take a listen to this.
Oh yeah.
I really don't like to use this language,
but I can't think of anything else.
You're so fully, I mean seriously, you need
to grow up and you need to realize this.
The progressive movement is not going to help
us do anything.
You need to change your allegiances and start
supporting, conserve the divide deal because
progressive ideals will lead us to nothing
but that soon we're actually going to do,
you're going to the country into the ground.
People like you and people like all these
progressive idiots who think, oh free this
free that, nothing's free brother.
And I figured you'd be old enough to know
that, but obviously you're not right.
You know my phone number is if the bowls call
me back and are arguing, you know what?
I think you should go on Hannity show until
him face to face.
What'd you say to him behind his back?
That's the best idea so far.
I would love to go on Hannity's show and talk
to them face to face anytime he wants to have
me, I'll be there.
There's this funny idea that you sometimes
hear from the right that progressive ideas
are childish and once you grow up or mature
you sort of grow out of those progressive
ideas and it's so laughable to me because
number one, it's based on the false premise
that people become more conservative as they
get older.
What, what the case is, is that successively
younger generations are more to the left for
their entire lives.
There's not actually evidence that individuals
become more conservative as they age.
That I've seen, willing to have my mind changed
on that.
But the idea of the childish and immature
ideas being on the left, the right beliefs
in great part that taxes or slavery or at
least should be almost completely eliminated
and that abortion is murder and that tax cuts
for the rich stimulate the economy.
I have a hard time thinking of any more childish
and immature ideas than those.
So those in glass houses definitely shouldn't
be throwing stones.
And as far as calling this guy, listen, I'm
a little busy producing the show and running
an ad agency to call and have off air conversations
with people.
But I welcome you and in fact, I invite you
to call in when we take live calls.
Uh, and I would love to have a conversation
with you about the supposedly immature progressive
ideas on the bonus show today.
A court has sided with the Trump administration
and a lawsuit over hotel profits.
That is an important decision.
Actually.
Uh, Disneyland has experienced a brawl and
the case related to that brawl has been sent
to Orange County prosecutors by the police
department.
And Pete Buddha judge has proposed a broad
plan to counter racial inequality and it has
some interesting things in it, has some ideas
that I think are good ones, some ideas that
are a little bit more of a question mark.
And we will be talking about all of those
ideas and many other big ideas.
I'm going to have to be in recovery mode all
weekend actually from so many high level ideas
on today's bonus show, get instant access.
Do it by becoming a member@joinpatterndotcomorbymakingapledgeonpatrioticatpatriondotcomslashdavidthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpacman.com
[inaudible].